[Music]
the name Henrietta Lacks may not be
well-known but her impact on the medical
community is long-lasting Lacs was a
mother of five diagnosed with cervical
cancer doctors took her cancer cells
without permission before she died the
cell became known as Gila
they are the basis for advances in
modern medicine like the polio vaccine
chemotherapy and in vitro fertilization
in the new HBO film The Immortal Life of
Henrietta Lacks will share her story it
is based on Rebecca scutes best-selling
non-fiction book of the same name now in
the film Oprah as in Winfrey there's
only one plays LAX's daughter Deborah
who goes on a mission to learn about her
mother Rose Byrne as a reporter Rebecca
Skloot and Hamilton star renee Elyse
Goldsberry portrays Henrietta Lacks now
my brothers all upset cuz they're
everybody come around make money off our
mama cells but I don't care nothin about
that what I care about is knowing about
my sister and knowing about my mother
and you gotta promise me no matter what
you ain't gonna lie and you ain't gonna
keep nothing from me I promise you
better get yourself ready girl cuz you
have no idea what you getting yourself
into
no idea you don't say that again Oprah I
got no idea what you don't you have any
idea literally
please and welcome 60 minutes News
special contributor that's Oprah along
with Rose Byrne when Rene Elise
Goldsberry to studio 57 welcome back to
the table this is the thing Oprah even I
who know you so well I lost all the
openness when I was watching you and I
didn't think that that was possible
that's good but everybody who has seen
that is saying that it's not just me but
it's interesting to hear you say that
you were intimidated I remember when you
took the role you said I just don't want
to embarrass myself
I did one words myself but I surrendered
to the hands of George Woolf the one and
only George Woolf director and director
George Woolf
and being able to work with these
wonderful women although we never had a
scene together yeah what makes it so
beautiful playing your mother this is
what I love undercover message she's my
mama my mama and you know I've never
heard of the story after all those years
working in Baltimore and have carried it
since 2010 she's based in Baltimore
since she was born and raised and died
in Baltimore and Rebecca Skloot as we
all know the author of The Immortal Life
of Henrietta Lacks the book brought the
story to light so thank you Rebecca
Skloot for doing that and making this
possible for all of us underline the
greatness of her in terms of what she
contributed yes yes uh her cells which
are still duplicating as we speak
replicating as we speak
helped contribute to the polio vaccine
to the AIDS cocktail to practically
every piece of medicine that now is in
existence has some form of gila gila has
contributed to it talk about that Renee
cause you were Henrietta Lacks
contribution is amazing the story that
most of us have never heard of and it's
what's a story that we can get so caught
up in the science of it because it's
still so controversial but I love to
talk about the beauty of just a woman
who was so young and seemingly so
disenfranchised and the the impact that
she had and especially when you look at
her family today
and see all the things that they're they
continue to contribute
two generations three generations later
I think it's just really an empowering
story that should inspire all of us to
tell our stories to our children I
thought the same thing Andros you pay
Rebekah's loot the author the journalist
who her dogged pursuit to tell this
story to form this friendship with
Deborah to help her discover her mother
it's such a beautiful story what did you
learn in meeting with Rebecca Rebecca is
really a force of nature
she is incredibly smart but incredibly
determined and if she has her mind on
something she will get it and she's in
it but she's a very impressive person
and I got to spend quite a bit of time
with her she was very candid with
everyone of a person there we are you
know she she's very candid and she had a
lot of stuff of me that's not in the
book about her own you know personal
life Rose I love how Norris has formed
this friendship with Deborah because
Deborah was a little crazy again you
guys have a real bumpy journey to get to
get to a place where there's
understandable she was paranoid she'd
been you know a be like 42 medications
it's interesting because there are a
couple of times when we were really
sitting together and being friendly in
Georgia no no no no too friendly to
persuade enough of that yeah right
nothing there's a great scene where she
grabs you
Deborah grabs you and throws you up
against one you tell her to shut the
bleep up
Oprah has anybody ever said that I got a
kick out of that so I never said that to
me in real life yeah bleep up yeah you
know when you get told [ __ ] that's what
I was wondering there's a moment where
you just go we're men who you talking to
yeah I wanted that about you calf it
because number one you were so
convincing when you said it yeah and I
thought god I wonder how she's taking
that in that many times it's a long day
we shut the bleep up all day long no
George was a he was a great leader we
all kind of leant on him yeah yes George
I'm just askin he added to this yeah I
mean he's he's a genius he's a national
treasure he's you know at Broadway I
Tony award-winning iconic director and
writer and it's actually the first time
I got to work with him I heard a quote
that you said that Audra McDonald told
you that you're you would become a
better actor from yes Audra McDonald and
I had done a table read for night mother
with George Woolf and Scott Sanders that
never came to be but Georgia MacDonald
said to me if you ever get a chance in
life to be directed by George Woolf take
it because he will change you as a
person and as an actress because you
weren't even going to be in this because
you wanted to work with Joel I wanted I
did this because I wanted to work with
George and I did this because when I
first heard the tapes that Rebecca
Skloot the author of the book had of
Deborah she had hours and hours and the
tapes it ever Deborah actually wanted me
to play her oh my gosh I just got the
chiller okay watch the Oprah show yeah
but they don't open today so I can hear
her voice saying that and I can hear her
saying that she wished that I would
prefer she wanted me to play her mother
and then realize I was too old to play
her mother and that would be better
playing her so it's prophetic yes it
feels prophetic I feel like you know
this coming into fruition is a part of
her dream and we always felt on set
anytime something would go right or
wrong Henriette was a Henrietta yes
thinking about this telling the story
too is the immense contribution that
Henrietta Lacks has made to science that
nobody knew about but it's also a story
of abuse yes the abuse of her in her
contribution not only taking her cells
without her knowledge which has now been
changed you have to give permission but
also then not even not even
acknowledging her they tried to change
her name call her Helen Lane yes HeLa
because they didn't want anybody to know
that those were her cells and then
wanted to be identified as this
african-american woman I mean I think
you think of all the people who have
benefited from her cells through
you know medical science a lot of them
not knowing that this was an
african-american women's contribution
that that you know led to their own
personal healing so we feel it's a
victory to get the story made are you
acting more and enjoying it more it
seems like I am and you know it wasn't
an intentional thing charlie I you know
this I'd held this as a producer and had
thought of other people who should have
played the role and it is because of
George and Lynn Amato from HBO he said
you need to do it and then when I heard
the tapes of Debra I said okay I'll do
it but it was I was very much
intimidated because everyone has done
more films than I have so I'm not
accustomed to stepping into a situation
where you know I'm the person on in the
room who is the least experienced was
she any good Rose I would love to be on
this set with it we had it she was
fantastic and all and unvarying a lot of
late night scene we did have a lot of
late nights things like and and not hurt
you know very conserving your energy and
meditative about the whole process and
very you know which I totally respect
you got a huge undertaking physically
and Rose rose we're coming in the
morning because she'd been up with the
baby all night and so it's right to
think about whaler is the chair sleep
about that's a late night with the baby
and you gotta do a comedy that was my
other thing I kept telling you I I'm
funnier than most people know I want as
a late in an hour laugh out loud
roll over honey go away the most manoa
be a much funnier than I appear to be
but of course a project comes with
controversy because a member of
Henrietta Lacks family one of her sons
is complaining that their mother was
exploited what do you say about that
because I know you work very closely
with the with the lacks well we you know
that first picture that you saw of us
that you just showed that was the first
day that we had all gone to Baltimore to
meet with the family let me say I think
there's one family member who's
disgruntled the rest of the family were
consultants on this young and the one
family member whose disgruntle as it
turns out from a story I read in the
Washington Post by a by Steve's somebody
was great story
had never has never river book never
under before seen the forcing the film
offers of them so my feeling is you
don't get a right to complain if you
haven't read the book okay you need to
at least read the book so and if you go
to Instagram you'll see Rebecca Skloot
walking around New York City with
Henrietta Lacks granddaughter and
daughter-in-law and great-granddaughter
there's taking pictures in front of the
Henrietta Lacks posters that are up so
happy and excited I think there is a
disgruntled family family right okay
well I know yet okay I do it okay how
you doing here oh well you'll be part of
us yeah welcome to family and you visit
your cbs2 yes I have my first meeting
tomorrow okay yes with the Jeff Bader
graduation thanks you know crow hey and
Rose congratulations the immortal act
immortal life brother of Henrietta Lacks
premieres Saturday on HBO